وارحب هنا بالزميل عبد الله ملكاوي عبد
الله كنت شاهدا على الساعات الاولى من هذه
الحرب التي ما زالت متواصله كيف كانت ردود
الفعل حينها على مستوى السكان في العاصمه
كياف وايضا كيف كنتم تنظرون الى هذه الحرب
التي اندلعت في اوروبا
كريمه لم يكن يتوقع احد اول غالبيه لم تكن
تتوقع هذا الهجوم المباغت وبهذه الكثافه
على العاصمه الكل كان يتوقع ان تبدا الحرب
من الشرق حيث اصلا هي كانت بدات بين
الانفصاليين الموالين لروسيا في دنيا في
منطقه الدومباس والجيش الاوكراني منذ 2014
والحرب دائره فالجميع كان يتوقع ان تبدا
الحرب من هناك ان تدخل القوات الروسيه ومن
ثم تبدا حرب على الحدود الاوكرانيه لكن
قله كانوا يتوقعون ان تبدا الحرب ايضا
بالعاصمه كيف لذلك عمت حلم من نحن وصلنا
في الثالث والعشرين من شهر الشباط فبراير
من العام الماضي اي قبل انطلاق الحرب
بساعات ربما في في المساء واتذكر كان حل
مدينه كييف يعني اشبه بالطبيعي وان كان
القلق يعم تحدثنا اليهم لكن كان اشباب
طبيعي ذهبنا الى احد المطاعم لنتناول وجبه
العشاء وخلدنا الى النوم وفي يعني في في
ليله في ليله الرابع والعشرين عند الثانيه
فجرا تقريبا
استيقظنا على صفارات الانذار بدانا نسمع
سفارات الانذار وهنا علمنا ان الحرب قد
بدات ان كيف معنيه مباشره بهذه الحرب حاله
الذعر عمه الجميع لدرجه اننا في الصباح
الباكر يعني بدانا بالعمل منذ ساعات
الاولى
24 منذ من بدايه الحرب لكن الملفت وعندما
ذهبنا الى الفندق الى مكان الاستقبال في
ساعات الصباح الاولى ربما عند الحاديه
عشره صباحا لم نجد عمال الفندق الكل غادر
احد اكبر الفنادق في العاصمه كيف هناك كان
معظم التلفزيونات والمحطات والجهات
الاعلاميه في على مستوى العالم كانت في
الفندق وتفاجئنا بانه لم يعد هناك اي موظف
في الفندق بقينا لوحدنا تركوا كل شيء
وذهبوا وهذا يدل على حاله الذعر وعلى ان
الجميع لم يكن يتوقع هذه الحرب وكان هناك
خوف كبير وبالتالي اضطررنا كل الصحفيين
طروا الى ترك الفندق لانه لا يوجد اي شخص
ليؤدي اي خدمه
للصحفيين وبالتالي اضطررنا كل بدا يبحث عن
فندق وكان هناك صعوبه بجد الفنادق لان
الفنادق كانت تغلق
ويهرب اصحاب الفنادق او العمال وبالتالي
الكل لجا الى بعض الفنادق الصغيره وكانت
الظروف العمل
ايضا محدده اي بان الفندق الذي كنا فيه
كان فندقا يقدر علينا وجبه واحده في اليوم
الطعام واحد كميه محدده
ليستطيع الاستمرار على مدى الوقت في في ظل
الحرب وايضا منذ تلك الليله التي تحدثت
عنها
كان كل ما يعني السكان كيف تقريبا ينامون
في القابون نحن ايضا في الفنادق والبعض او
جزء كبير بدا بالاتجاه الى محطات القطار
ومغادره المدينه والهرب من المدينه
حاولت الدخول الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه
اسقاط النظام وفشلت في ذلك السؤال الان
كيف نجحت اوكرانيا في تغيير المخطط الروسي
بدايه القوات الروسيه حاولت ان تباغت
اوكرانيا والنظام الاوكراني وان
تهاجم العاصمه كييف وان تسقط النظام ان
تضع يدها على هذا الرجل الذي يعني اشغل
روسيا وبوتين وحتى الان واصبح يعني احد
يعني ابرز الشخصيات هذه الحرب زينسكي
بوليود رئيسها الاوكراني الذي ابدى صمودهم
منذ اللحظات الاولى لهذه من الحرب كانوا
يريدون ان يسقطوا العاصمه يسقط النظام
ويضع يدهم على الرئيس الاوكراني حتى ان
الولايات المتحده اقترحت على الرئيس
زينسكي
باخراجه من كييف وبارسال قوات تخرجه من
كييف سالما قبل ان يتم القبض عليه او ان
يتم اغتياله من قبل القوات الروسيه لكنه
رفض كما نعلم
[موسيقى]
ضخمه نقل الجنود ونقل الاليات وبالتالي
تكون على بعد عشرات الكيلومترات فقط من
كييف وتحاول اسقاط المدينه دارت معارك
يعني شرسه جدا وهنا بدات القوات
الاوكرانيه تبدي
استعداداتها الكبيره وشراستها والمعنويات
العاليه لديها في مواجهه هذا الهجوم
الروسي سنستمع الى بعض الجنود الذين
التقيناهم نحن في اليوم السادس والعشرين
بعد يومين من انطلاقه الحرب كانوا في
مناطق
مراقبه للجسور التي تحاول القوات الروسيه
عبورها نستمع لبعض هؤلاء الجنود يعني لنرى
مدى العزيمه الذي كان لدى الجنود
الاوكرانيين
روحونا القتاليه عاليه بنسبه 120 بالمئه
نحن مستعدون للدفاع عن بلدنا لن نستسلم
ابدا
انه سياتي الى هنا ويطيح بزلنسكي لانه لا
يناسبه لكنه يناسبنا
لسنا خائفين لقد سئمنا الخوف ليس لدينا
خيار اخر غير الدفاع عن بلدنا علينا ان
ننتصر من اجل الاجيال المقبله من اجل
مستقبلنا وحريتنا
قبل حمل السلاح كان هذا المتطوع محاميا
ككثيرين هبوا للدفاع عن الوطن
موب عدد الراغبين بالتطوع للقتال اكبر
منطقتنا لاستعابيه لذا نحاول تنظيم
العمليه
كل المتطوعين المحليين
عبد الله العزيمه نفسها بعد عام من الحرب
نعم عزيمه الجنود الكبيره
والاعداد الكبيره للمتطوعين كما راينا هي
ايضا شكلت تحولا في هذه الحرب ولا يزال لا
تزال هذه العزيمه وهذا التطوع مستمرا ولا
تزال الحرب مستمره بكل تاكيد شكرا
على هذه الشهاده الحيه من ارض المعركه